Let's apply the work
energy theorem principle
to the motion of a block
sliding down an inclined plane.
And here is an inclined
plane at an angle, theta.
And lets choose a
coordinate system.
We'll choose x equals 0
up here, or i-hat here.
And here is our
coordinate function.
And suppose that the
object starts at xi,
that it ends at x final.
If we want to calculate
the work energy then
what we're going to learn
is that this theorem
is two different sides.
Calculating the change
in kinetic energy
is simply a description.
This is 1/2 M v final squared
minus 1/2 v initial squared.
That's a property,
parameters of the system,
at the initial state, the
speed, or the velocity's speed,
which is speed squared.
And the same property v
final in the final state.
Now over here we have
two types of forces
acting on this object.
So here we need a free-body
force diagram first.
And this side is where the
physics [INAUDIBLE] lie.
And so we want to draw
our force diagram.
So if we have our block,
we have the friction force,
we have the normal
force, we have mg.
Recall, if the plane
is inclined theta
that's also the angle theta.
If we chose i-hat,
j-hat unit vectors,
I just want to repeat that
on my free-body diagram.
Now we can think of
this integral as just
one-dimensional motion
in the x direction.
And so we have two
different forces
that we have to calculate.
The friction force is
in the minus x direction
so we're integrating minus the
friction force with respect
to displacement from
x initial to x final.
And what about the
gravitational force?
Well the gravitational force
has a component, mg sine
theta in the x direction.
So when we integrate
that x component
we have now plus because
it's in the same direction.
Remember, we're displacing a
little bit dx down the inclined
plane so we're going from x
initial x final of mg sine
theta, which is a constant, dx.
And so when you're applying
the work energy theorem
you need to
integrate your forces
and actually calculate the work.
Now again, if you looked
in the j-hat direction,
and we applied Newton's second
law, n minus mg cosine theta 0,
and our rule for friction
is its mu k times
n or mu k mg cosine
theta, then what
we have is in both instances
we have a constant force.
So it's just force
times displacement.
So we have minus mu k mg cosine
theta times the displacement,
which is x initial x final.
Over here we have mg sine theta
times x final minus x initial.
And now we've calculated
separately both sides
of our work kinetic
energy principle.
As in all our physical
laws the equal sign
means the work is equal to
the change in kinetic energy.
I'll emphasize that by now
placing the equal sign because
of our physical law.
And so equaling 1/2 M v final
squared minus v initial mean
squared.
And now I have a relationship
between the parameters
of the initial state, which
I'm calling x initial and v
initial, and the parameters
that describe the final state, x
final, v final.
And depending on which set
of these parameters are given
I can conceivably solve
for the other ones.
One thing I do want
to point out when
we do this example is
we've described work
as a dot product from A to
B. Take the friction force.
Well in this instance, if
we wrote this out explicitly
it would be minus fk i-hat
dot dx i-hat from the initial
to the final.
i-had dot i-hat is 1.
And so you see, we recover from
x initial to x final of fk dx.
And that was the first piece.
The second piece, the
gravitational force,
dotted into ds from
x initial to x final.
Well, if you wrote down the
gravitational force, mg,
as a i-hat component
and a negative mg cosine
theta j-hat component, then when
we take the dot product again
where our ds-- here, we'll
write ds as dx i-hat--
then when you dot product
mg dot ds, mg dot ds,
we have i-hat dot
i-hat, which is one.
But j-hat dot i-hat, they're
perpendicular so that's 0,
so the only piece that survives
in the scalar product mg
dot ds is these two pieces.
And so we get the integral
from x initial to x
final of mg sine theta times dx.
And that's precisely
our second piece here.
So here's the simple application
of the work energy theorem.